in this video we are going to continue
our project by explaining the softmax
and cross-entropy concept which is
important for Mahler training from all
the training first we need to construct
a model instance using the model class
we defined before then we need to define
a loss function here we are using
cross-entropy
as the loss function that may sound
intimidating at first but don't worry
about it let's decode how to calculate
this cross entropy loss step by step
after getting the linear weighted sum
scores from the network we need to fit
it into a soft a max function softmax
function will normalize that the input
vector into the range from 0 to 1 which
can be interpreted as probability in
this way we can directly compare it to
the one hold included vector that
corresponds to your labels using cross
entropy this is the mass definition of
cross entropy notice that the lock
function can take zero however there is
a lot of zeroes in one hot encoding so
that the probability in the lock
function must come from the output of
the softmax function you can be assured
that the mathematically softmax function
will never produce 0 now let's see why
we want to optimize this cross entropy
loss for this one hot including vectors
where we have 1 when I equal to 3 and 0
for other classes the Koch entropy
function can be expanded where we only
have one term left where I equal to 3
our other term disappeared because of Li
equal to 0 so we only needs to focus on
one term on the model probability
outputs when I equal to 3 now if we want
to minimize cross entropy loss we need
to make log as term as small as possible
looking at the log function plot here as
needs to be very close to 1 in order to
follow Gaz to have a small value in such
a way by optimizing cross entropy loss
we can force the model to optimize these
parameters to make the right prediction
so that's the reason why we use cross
entropy as loss function here and in the
next video we are going to talk about
how to use back propagation to optimize
model parameters with this loss function
don't forget to subscribe to us and rain
the notification bow and stay tuned